David if Donald Trump is unfortunately
reelected in November of 2020 how bad do
you think his second term would be so in
thinking about a trump second term there
are two sides to it one is Trump is
incredibly childish and vindictive the
other side is Trump is incredibly lazy
so I would predict that a second term
Trump would simultaneously be more
unhinged and brazen and authoritarian
and going after his political enemies
using executive orders to do whatever he
wants more frequently but at the same
time I see him watching a lot more TV
and playing a lot more golf and being
even lazier than he has been because
he's not gonna have anything else to
campaign for maybe towards the end of
his second term Trump would have a
Republican nominee to campaign for if
they believed that it would be useful
remember back in 2008 you didn't see
george w bush campaigning for john
mccain very much because george w bush's
approval rating was in the toilet and it
wouldn't have been a good thing for
mccain to have bush out there
prominently so i would expect a few
different things trump's not gonna have
his rally so he'll watch more TV and
play more golf he'll feed his ego on
twitter in terms of what he will get
done
certainly donald trump will continue to
get a lot done on judges because trump
is just the tool in mitch mcconnell's
toolbox so to speak when it comes to
judges and they will continue they may
get more Supreme Court justices on the
court depending on who goes and who
stays in Trump second term they will
keep putting more federal judges in and
so no doubt if Trump is given four more
years laziness aside tweeting aside his
effect on the Jewish judiciary is going
to be absolutely damaging for decades to
come that's going to continue beyond
that I don't believe you will see Trump
do much of significance when it comes to
big policy achievements I don't think
Trump will get anything done on health
care the way he promised to do during
his first term and a lot of the reason
is Trump doesn't really believe in what
he's doing you know Trump put together
this faux conservative ideology where he
pretended to care about debt
he pretended to care about you know
stopping abortion and stuff he didn't
care about his entire life and Trump's
ideology is not a conservative ideology
it's what I call and sort of imbecilic
reactionary ideology where Trump just is
very opinionated and in some cases he is
very reactionary in other cases he's
libertarian in the sense that he doesn't
care what people do he's taking
positions on some of these issues
because he's figured out that it appeals
to evangelical and other right-wing
voters so because Donald Trump doesn't
really have a very important or
significant political ideology as such I
think Trump will not get much done at
all and he's just gonna kind of hang out
now his authoritarianism combined with
his vindictive nature to me suggests
that in addition to helping Mitch
McConnell get his judges in maybe trying
to you know get some kind of tax cuts
done and putting continuing to tweet and
watch TV there is a very good chance
that Donald Trump is going to really
start taking his anger out even more on
media people that he doesn't like on
politicians that he feels haven't been
supportive enough of him so I would
expect a second term Trump will really
try to ruin people's lives his enemies
live is the people that he perceives as
his Ammon enemies or not having been
with him while he mostly just rubber
stamps whatever Republicans convince him
to do it will be very very ugly it will
be very ugly and it is of course no I
don't want to say renewed importance
because it's been of constant importance
that we do everything we can to remove
this guy in November please don't forget
that Monday Memorial Day we have a
one-day David Pakman show membership
explosion planned it's been months since
we did any of these big membership
specials Monday everybody on our mailing
list will get an email the email will
say a lot of good things about you it
will say you're a beautiful person
you're a tremendous a tremendously good
person for being on our mailing list and
watching the show listed oh you know
will sing your praises but then here's
the key part
the email that goes out on Memorial Day
will tell you how to get a disgustingly
I mean this is it's a vilely you've is
that word it's a vile huge discount off
of membership and it'll be a one-day
special okay get on the mailing list at
david pakman.com top right of the
website you type in your email address
you'll be on the mailing list Monday
you'll get an email with this membership
special and you will also as a member
get access to the bonus show which today
is hosted by producer Pat he will talk
to you on the bonus show momentarily I
will be back with you that next week